[Music]
I'm not getting in trouble with your
with your wife does it ever does she
ever get mad at you over the choices you
make and raising the children you got a
bad yeah that's on the list you know of
things she gets mad at she hears the
problem is because with my kids my wife
doesn't kind of get me like the kids get
me you know we were this is a true story
this was about a year ago we were taking
my 14 year old to see the movie Ted
mm-hmm yeah yeah is that radio outlets
are it's rated R yeah and it's a pretty
it's a pretty hard R to language what's
a teddy bear yeah it's a oh sure all
right but we were taking him and his two
buddies you know he had his two buddies
with them and they were in the back seat
and my wife said it we what are we doing
are we doing the right thing here so I
said to the guys they're in the back
seat and I said all right boys listen up
there's gonna be stuff in this movie
that may be inappropriate to hear or see
so we're gonna use a code word we use a
code word and when I say that code word
you cover your ears and your eyes okay
and the code word is [ __ ]
and my wife it was like I was a dog who
peed on the carpet she was like no I was
like I gotta get on the left the kids
were hysterical yeah you killed you
can't do yeah and she said she I said I
gotta get to laughs and she said why
couldn't use a different word then I say
you don't get it in that split second I
went through the rolodex of words there
was only one other word that would get
that laughs and it's worse than that you
did the right is the lesser of the two
words